welcome to another challenge with Ethan
and Tyler it's me mark sandy was so
packed full of sand
Oh a pearl notice in there with his tiny
penis oh so small we are here to conquer
cake once and for all
introducing Tyler the Ethan shine and
Ethan boo Tyler's ride together they
make Thai fans know you can get your ass
in here ha ha Wow oh we're going in raw
who's been writing in his basement alone
for years his grandchildren never called
but when he makes this book what's it
called horses presidents keep working on
writing the nuts it's me
markiplier the sausage I'd like to
welcome to the stage wingus in dingus
just fit your pants
[Music]
[Laughter]
we got buckets with which to do it we
got [ __ ] do you not feel the same when
you look at me then I feel the boss
drawing your
maybe David over there with
[Music]
[Music]
I am the man who owns four ovens who
owns five ovens who wants to write first
that's not an answer
[Music]
sticking a hand in business Oh perfect
it looks just like a boob oh never mind
looks more like a little bit never
painted before in my life never never
not even finger paint no well maybe I
don't know we're porch we didn't have
finger there was chocolate this beat
together the yolks oh I did it wrong
didn't I
we never made the whole cube there put
back the back in your bowl [ __ ] then it
doesn't take quite a big boy what
exactly my engineer my ass Jesus Christ
happy little accident
extremely sandy vagina thank you
who made the Mona Lisa Leonardo DiCaprio
that's it I gotta say guys I got a whole
load of presentation I would say it's a
it's a patriotic glory
I'm making a me birthday cake did you
have birthday cake well you do now and
ring Pandurang you know I mean Los
America actually I've written plenty of
short stories that's a question yes this
is why he's a master here's a sink for
you we will do it Tyler first just
because I want it to piss him off don't
worry about a thing
nothing gonna spread that much flavor to
you
today jr. screams sugar
what does brulee me in French what does
brulee in French mean what are you
gloating when you have that then your
hair yes they accurately your dreams and
aspirations yes for a diamond play
button uh-huh and you're a ghost because
you're dead oh just like my channel what
was that I missed it I wasn't looking
what is blinking it's squeezing your
salivary glands to you mouth Jack you
late at all for my dick you're gonna
have to taste that you're gonna have to
taste this
[Applause]
[Music]
martial judges I'm sending a telekinetic
burst see when I've had creme brulee I
felt like there was no flavor other than
the caramelized sugar on top that's
that's how I
oh it's got some it tastes I've managed
to create the world's first
wrist-mounted fullest stealthy you
wouldn't even know that there was a
ballista look at the range on this bad
boy
[Laughter]
obviously it's between mark and me and
mark is definitely the such tough
competition with Tyler here
- that's a bad one thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye
[Music]
[Music]